all right it's time for our scene an
unseen segment where we expose the big
cultural stories of the day
impeachment style battle what SML and a
legendary actor go all-in for pushing
the president out joining us with all
the details Raymond Arroyo Fox News
contributor right Raymond and all the
impeachment drama and it is drama it is
three acts you saw something else today
that could affect the outcome what is it
yeah well you know I always look lor for
the pop culture play how this is being
received by everyday Americans so I
wanted to compare the style not the
substance of what Nancy Pelosi and the
president said today Speaker Pelosi
started by noting the historicity of
this day we also here today on the
one-year anniversary of the khashoggi
okay
since Khashoggi always count it's such a
very sad thing that's not the only sad
thing this impeachment battle laura is
first and foremost a political
communications tussle in between lost
words and missing trains of thoughts
Pelosi sought to align her cause with
that of the father's not that we place
ourselves in a category of greatness of
our founders but we do place ourselves
in a time of urgency on the threat to
the Constitution a system of checks and
balances that is being made it's
wandering Laura it's unfocused I just
you can imagine how Americans are
receiving this though she's not helping
her cause even if she had a great
argument she's deliberately she's
sitting her summer with reading like
Federalist 218 the travel I mean she's
not doing any of that okay but but what
about when she paused it was very
obvious a horrific murder of khashoggi
and she kind of that was an odd yeah it
was a bizarre it wasn't weird turn that
yeah
all right here is the president from the
Oval Office today
when a whistleblower okay are you ready
I heard the whistle blowers report from
you people this country has to find out
who that person was because that
person's a spy in my opinion you ready I
thought I have to note something here
look he's taking the leakers a spy right
but he's all in this thing and he uses a
tactic and I watched it repeated where
he goes you're ready and then he drops
the line makes you stop ready he makes
you
I'm gonna give it to you now it's a
tactic now we're to go back to Pelosi
watch the contrast in communications
here
it's very sad I don't see impeachment as
a unifying thing for our country I
weighed those equities hard and long
don't had the president's admission that
he did what he did
it's wonder he did what he did what did
he do and it's sad what he did and it's
unifying it's not unifying that she does
that weird thing with her mouth well the
other the dentures it's certain realize
that but watch how Trump channels
passion for maximum I love this Biden
and his son our stone called crooked
and you know it his son walks out with
millions of dollars the kid knows
nothing you know it and so do we he had
the same approach on the Oval Office he
was emphatic about this he's indignant
over it it matters to him he looks like
he's in the game Pelosi looks like she's
trying to convince the faculty lounge to
add a smoke room you know it's and
quoting things now the pop culture
shapes the the opinions of many
Americans when it comes to these hot
political topics this week SNL opened
their 45th season with a desperate
president facing impeachment watch give
me Rudy Giuliani on the phone what's new
what do you mean what's new Rudy being
impeached I got another call okay who's
this
it's Attorney General bar stay calm mr.
president I know things look bad right
now but I got our top guy on this good
well let's get him on the phone too none
of that's working Laura
it's not working and the ratings have
proven 30% drop again the same percent
from UT for that opening Raymond is
really good impressionist and you can do
a group Rudy Guiliani that Kate year in
and was embarrassed that was a bomb
beginning if you're gonna do Rudy early
is really out or I'm gonna we're gonna
we're suing everyone go get a bowl of
soup to start including you Laura I'm
gonna start will be ring no no never
gonna come on again all right Raymond
before we go our old pal Bob De Niro
we're very close to aim at us over the
past weekend now you're gonna remember
we took him on for cursing out the
president at the Tony Awards but even
before that in January of 2018
I remember this idiot is the president
the guy is a fool he's just off the
rails well he's one of the great actors
of his generation but it undermines the
work when you engage in this kind of ad
hominem well De Niro then went on CNN
this past weekend to respond to well us
when you say that folks on Fox come
after you I remember the Tonys when he
got up there and cursed a lot of you
this guy is like a gangster he's come
along and he's said things done things
we say over and over again this is
terrible this guy is crazy we've got to
get him out well just because he played
a gangster doesn't mean he knows what
again so you know when a beloved actors
somebody look up to for their great art
now one date without a screenwriter they
collapse into profanities and have
little insight here it's not edifying
this was once a great actor he's pushing
this movie the Irishman which should be
called the airbrush man because walking
him back his age back through a CGI
I really don't like but anyway this is
cheap and low and it's beneath Robert De
Niro why do I always think he's Dustin
Hoffman I don't know I have a thing with
Dustin Hoffman Al Pacino Al Pacino De
Niro's a movie together so yeah they're
all kind of diminutive thanks Raymond I
know that's I don't mean that in a bad
way though I know brilliant genius
actors